okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
so i'm happy to try and answer questions
about
history science technology mathematics
both things that i've personally been
involved in and things that i might have
studied from the more distant past
so let's see we have some questions
saved up here there's one from them
gaddy
can we consider very early games like
the game of go as an expression of a
mathematical thinking
it's an interesting question
you know there are games that date i
think go
uh probably not quite knowing when it
originated
but certainly in antiquity you know a
couple of thousand years ago or more
chess likewise and so on
there are definitely and and there are
other games like um
uh what is it nine man's morris it's in
the old game there's the the royal game
of ur which presumably had something to
do with the city of ur in in the
babylonian times
um
so there are definitely games from 4 000
years ago and so on um and
you know in most cases we kind of know
how they were played we know what the
rules but we know we know we have boards
and we can deduce
um
something about how they were played
and
so a question would be what's the
relationship between those games
and
kind of mathematical kind of work
i'm not sure that's very clear
i think one thing you might ask is if
you look at let's say babylonian tablets
there were plenty that had things like
mathematical word problems on them and
there were others that had kind of
designed like
game-like boards
and there were still others that had
kind of mathematical patterns so let's
take another example of something sort
of a crossover between the game and the
mathematics which is mazes
so
there are
uh recently saw a babylonian tablet that
has an array of i don't know six or
eight different maze-like patterns on it
which i thought was very interesting
and an example of something not that
different from the kind of enumerate
possible programs for things but it's
just one tablet and has no context all
it has is pictures of those mazes on it
it has no kind of explanatory leaflet
that comes with it or anything that's
just here are some maze-like things
in in the past uh well certainly there's
one particular maze pattern
that
is uh often found in lots of different
places i mean it was it was said at one
time to have been the
the design of uh the labyrinth on at
knossos and on crete that was the you
know the home of the minotaur and other
times it was said to be the the logo of
the city of troy it had a lot of
distinguished history but it's one
particular maze pattern out of many and
is that mathematical is that more
recreational is it more like a game it's
not really clear it's not clear quite
how that intent really worked out
i think a thing that um
uh
is some
something
to think about in in terms of these
things is the
the sort of relationship of quotes
recreational mathematics
to the actual doing of mathematics
for a long time
there have been
sort of um well another question sort of
who does mathematics
mathematics is done
uh in in antiquity in in babylon and
places like that plenty of mathematics
was done
for the sake of actually doing
commercial transactions
collecting taxes things like this
but you know when you look at the
mathematical exercises that were given
there some of them
were
almost recreational exercises
they were kind of questions that were
sort of a fun question
that perhaps was a question intended to
be
something that would encourage the
student to think math was interesting
but might have been just sort of a fun
question
for example good example from 1205
i guess uh
uh leonov though fibonacci's uh libra
obachi the book of the abacus
is mostly a book about sort of doing
arithmetic and importing hindu arabic
numerals to the west
but at the end of that book is this
problem about rabbits
and you know rabbits in this year and
they have some number of uh each rabbit
has two rabbits
has you add together the number of
rabbits et cetera et cetera et cetera
that was the origination of the
fibonacci series what was it doing there
it's at the very end of libero barchi
it's the very last section what was it
doing was it recreational math was it
kind of a practice exercise for people
who had learned arithmetic i don't think
it's very clear it's just given there as
they consider this problem it's you know
you can consider it
but i think that the um this question of
sort of the the recreational and the um
uh
and the kind of
the
well there's there's three things
there's games there's recreational math
and there's math
that is being done for furthering the
practice of math or for the applications
of math
even the idea of sort of recreational
math
had sort of separate tracks i'll give
you an example
uh digit sequences
there are lots of kind of recreational
math problems you know can you if you
have a a thing written out with letters
you know can you fill in digits that
will correspond to these letters to make
it a valid addition some
can you do a sudoku-like thing okay can
you do
these kinds of things which are sort of
quotes recreational math
and
the question of sort of the interface
between those things and professional
math is interesting sometimes it's there
sometimes it isn't there were in past
centuries people would publish
uh you know books of sort of
recreational math
those people were typically not
you know it's it's so complicated
because there was so much overlap
between these different areas there are
people who were definitely recreational
mathematicians
um who would publish sort of books of
puzzles and they would write the the
puzzle column of a newspaper things like
that but those people were not typically
professional mathematicians
then there were also
i would say professional mathematicians
who who rather turn their nose up at the
sort of the recreational math oh who
cares about fidget sequences that's just
in recreational math type thing that
kind of thing
but then there were occasionally cases
where people would sort of dip into the
recreational for some scientific purpose
i mean i can give you an example of that
in my own kind of life and times the the
game of life cellular automaton that
john conway developed
um
was uh
back in 1968 or so
was something that a lot of people kind
of studied
for recreational purposes
they had found oh there's this cute
configuration of cells and it does this
and it does that
back in the early 1980s i went and tried
to collect all that stuff
because i wanted to try and do some
science on it i want to try and figure
out some general principles about how
cellular automaton like that might work
in fact recently i've been planning a
project of looking at kind of the meta
engineering of the game of life people
have over the 50 years that the the
quotes game has existed
that people have uh
uh found all kinds of elaborate
configurations they've been whole chains
of sort of engineering that have been
developed about how you make glider guns
street glider streams that do this and
that and the other and it's very
interesting to see because it's a case
where you can kind of trace the history
of engineering not in something which
has constraints of physicality but just
something where it's a pattern of bits
and it's like well what pattern of bits
do people learn about and understand and
and build from and so that's sort of an
interesting case where i've been sort of
trying to science defy what has been
essentially a recreational activity
i think that um
are many interesting crossovers the
rubik's cube was an interesting
crossover it was at some level design
developed as kind of a design exercise
then it became kind of this
uh this sort of math-like thing but very
quickly in that case there were
particular mathematicians who were sort
of cross-over mathematicians like there
was a person david singh master i think
who was an early person who came in to
do sort of the group theory of the
rubik's cube but he's also a person who
has
extensively catalogued and studied
recreational mathematics but he's also a
mathematician
even something like the quotes game of
life which is sort of billed as a game
john conway eventually admitted to me
after a very long conversation once that
he actually invented it for for real
sort of mathematical purposes about
enumerating recursive functions but he
sort of said he thought people would be
more impressed if he presented it as a
game
so that's a confusing case
i think
the question of games
as like chess and things like that are
they mathematical problems well for a
long time chess was not sort of thought
about mathematically
eventually by the end of the 1800s
people had started to think about sort
of things like chess more mathematically
i think the idea of a game tree
was something developed around 1912-ish
time frame um that was uh by a person
from set theory actually um i think that
was uh zamelo uh inventor of um uh the
sort of standard axioms of set theory um
co-inventor of the
zf axioms of set theory
um but
you know what he was what a game tree a
game tree is asking given that you're in
this configuration of the game there's a
sort of tree of possibilities you can
you can make this move at the next step
and the next move you can make further
branches from each of those branches and
so on but that idea of sort of
mathematicizing chess
um was an idea that that arose at that
time i i think
it had been kind of sort of hinted at
by people writing chess books
and then
it was kind of jumped in on by sort of
the actual mathematicians and then that
sort of gradually evolved in that
direction
um so i i'm i'm i think there's a sort
of a
it's surprising that chess has existed
for thousands of years and not been a
source of like math problems now it's
worth remembering for example card games
games of chance
in the 1600s that was what led the
bernoullis
to um uh to get interested in um
improbability theory was you know what
could you do from games of chance that
was a case where in a sense the um
uh those that the kind of um the the the
game was mathematicized um and and led
to a bunch of mathematics uh you can
also ask the the opposite question when
has sort of mathematics led to things
which were
uh kind of recreational
um
i'm trying to think of good examples of
that i remember one tetris for example a
game of you know falling blocks and you
arranged them and so on i think that was
a former student of a former employee of
ours who was um
a russian physics mathematical physicist
um
who um
had been studying
things about
um
statistical mechanics and um and so on
and and tetris was kind of a
a
uh something that came out of
essentially the the mathematics
of or the mathematical physics of um
uh of things about crystals and so on
and that was kind of an idea that was
was spawned from that
i mean i suppose the question you could
ask um
in uh
um
you know to what extent
are the people who are
impressive players of different kinds of
games
um also the mathematicians one thing
that's always interesting about a game
like chess
is that this sort of the range of
different kinds of people and
backgrounds of people who are sort of
serious chess players is extremely
diverse
in a sense probably more diverse than
the backgrounds of people who are going
to be sort of pure mathematicians for
instance
um so but i think that the overlap
between sort of the great chess players
and the great mathematicians um there's
a you know they're disjoint sets with a
small overlap
um
and uh
i think um so so
i i would tend to think that
the
the interface between games and
mathematics was not as great as one
might think it kind of well it feels
like the same kind of thing but i think
operationally it was practiced for
different motivations and probably by
largely different people would be my
guess but but knowing
really what the origination of some of
these games and so on
were
is is difficult um i mean i don't think
one knows
uh for example the game of go to take
that as an example the game of go is not
an easy game to analyze mathematically
it's actually super hard
um
and i'm not sure that that's a case
where
in a sense
the you know you might say well i'm just
going to write down math you know i'm
going to say i've got a chess
board configuration i'm going to write
down math that says the score of this
chessboard configuration is x well it
doesn't work very well it's it's more
difficult than that it's a more
computational kind of problem a more
computationally irreducible kind of
problem and kind of the obvious math
doesn't work too well that one could
even argue that if the obvious math
works too well the game is not going to
be that interesting i mean in
tic-tac-toe for example where there are
only 4 000 board configuration 4 000
possible games you can play
and um the it's it's sort of rather easy
to analyze what happens it's not such an
exciting game and in fact one might even
argue that what makes a game
of the type of something like go or
chess
interesting is that it is not accessible
to something like mathematical analysis
um and so that that might be a reason
why
kind of the the process of of game
playing might be separate from um from
the process of sort of mathematical
analysis you know mathematical analysis
you try and get everything to the point
where you can sort of crush it all down
and explain everything
i suppose it's an interesting question
whether there's an interface between
that and for example programming uh for
computers and so on and again i don't
think there's a huge correlation there i
think those are pretty separate
kinds of activities you don't find you
know the chess grand masters aren't
particularly the great programmers and
vice versa there are certainly people
who have interest in both things for
example um well alan turing for instance
um did do some work on sort of making a
computer play chess but i think he was
more interested in the what can a
computer do than he was on the chess
side of it there was a person called
david champanone who was a
i think a friend of touring's in in
college in cambridge um who was also
involved in this uh can you make a chess
computer type thing i think david
champagne was a more serious chess
player who had been a mathematics
student later became a well-known
economist um but that was uh again you
know i think these are specific examples
and i don't think there's a general
trend there
let's see
um
well there's a there's a question here
from uh gecko
is science still the place where the
best thrive or has that shifted to
quotes industry what's the historical
context
well
you know
science
has only been a professionalized
activity for
well 150 years maybe it had a sort of a
build up over time i mean for a long
time
the way you got to do science
was you were either kind of
independently wealthy
or you had a day job that was being a
courtier in some court
or something something else and science
was a vocation that was done kind of on
the side
the professionalization of science
happens slowly i mean people like like
isaac newton was a professional
scientist he was the regis professor in
cambridge um presumably the fact that
it's called the regious professor means
it was paid for by the king although i'm
not not absolutely sure about that
um but the idea that there were people
who were professionals doing these kinds
of intellectual uh pursuits
was was not
has not been a thing for that long i
mean i think emmanuel kant was uh
probably the one of the first
professional philosophers so to speak
employed to be a professor of philosophy
so to speak
um even that even when you say a
professor of ex
does that really make you a professional
whatever it is because your real job in
a sense is teaching i mean i know when
when i was a professor long ago um in a
first approximation you know even the
fanciest research universities sort of
thought the the job was teaching and the
research was kind of an on the side
thing and it was more significant on the
side thing
if you were bringing in grants and
government money and all this kind of
thing for it but in a sense the thing
that people were being paid to do
was to teach
and research was kind of a
a
a sort of an add-on type thing
now the idea of
kind of the it's sort of been
interesting that
that there's been in some countries
there's been a kind of a a government
research strand an industrial research
stand as well as a university research
strand
and in different countries the relative
kind of uh prestige of those different
strands has been different
at different times in history also
and i think the uh
this idea
you know sometimes
in in a place like the us
there's sometimes
thought to be kind of a big pecking
order of you know the best universities
and the second best universities and so
on
and sometimes the government labs have
been kind of out of that pecking order
it's kind of like they're just the thing
a thing where people do research and
it's not like well this lab is better
than that lab and that's better you know
that slots into the university system in
this place they're kind of a different
track which is sort of an interesting
interesting case
i mean by the way it's worth remembering
that in the u.s
there are a few universities that have
sort of broad sort of uh
high
high sort of
achievement in a lot of different areas
but there's a lot of variation of you
know a university that may be kind of an
obscure university for some purposes
just has a fantastic department of acts
that got developed as a result of some
particular individual or some
coincidence of history or whatever else
but i think this question of of how do
people
uh you know where
how do people kind of get to a point
where they can be productive and work
they're doing
that's a complicated issue and it's not
even clear
that
you know there are some definite be
careful what you wish for type
situations
you know there can be cases like the
institute for advanced study where i
worked years ago now
um was kind of a place where been set up
in the 1930s and it was kind of a okay
now just go and think for the rest of
your life
well there are some people for whom
that's really a big win and wonderful
and they can be very productive and
there are also lots of people for for
whom this kind of okay
you've got 50 years just go think
is not a great way to be productive
um and so this idea about whether um
you know what
what counts as sort of being
a place where sort of you can be people
can be the most productive isn't clear
you know when it comes to this question
about what does it take to um to thrive
in different environments uh i mean this
is perhaps segwaying a little bit off
the topic of history but but um
uh
you know to be a modern academic
there is a definite track you have to
follow
and i you know it's like um
somebody was saying to me
just yesterday actually they were
explaining that um
they wanted to use ai as a generator of
text
why they were going to use it to
generate kind of boilerplate text for
academic papers that they were writing
and it's like by the time you've got
something where you are on a track where
you need boilerplate that is kind of
standardized text that could be written
by an ai something is wrong with this
picture
and you're you know you're in an
environment where where there's sort of
a certain layer of gunk
um that's that's involved that shouldn't
be you know part that's not part of the
kind of the intellectual story and i do
think that in modern academia it is
there is a um
uh there are definite sort of uh
games that get played and things people
have to do to succeed that don't
necessarily
relate to are they for example the most
productive innovative whatever kinds of
thinkers in fact you know it's fair to
say and i've probably said this many
times that if you want sort of the
when you have a big field
with lots of institutional structure
that is a terrible formula for having
sort of high-level innovation happen
because you end up with all these
systems that are just like well you've
got to be doing the same thing everybody
else is doing and so on and i think that
uh that's something that in a lot of
fields at universities and so on that's
what's happened now on the other side
you have uh sort of entrepreneurism and
the commercial sector and so on
and i would say
it's a it's a complicated story because
there was a time
when
uh starting a company was unusual
and
there were many kind of uh sort of there
was quite a
you had to kind of run quite a you know
down some kind of gauntlet type thing
of um uh to to actually get to the point
where you could start a company and
where where things worked and you know
incorporating it wasn't trivial and it
wasn't and and you know figuring out how
you do this part of setting up a company
and that part of setting up a company
and so on there it was non-trivial
now the sort of the process of
entrepreneurism has been somewhat more
institutionalized
venture capital is better understood
incubators have come up things like this
and so again it has both the advantage
that it's somehow easier to do but it
has the disadvantage that's become
institutionalized and it's like if you
say to some typical venture capitalist
might be even a you know i have many
friends in that in that field
you say well i want to do this weird
thing they're going to say
we don't want to deal with a weird thing
we we fund
this type of track
and that's a consequence of the fact
that they're funding many things every
year they've got a whole stick with
their upstream investors and etc etc etc
and it's not something where it's
possible to have this kind of high
innovation uh
situation
um so i mean it it's tricky because
there was there was a time when starting
a company
was difficult to do
but if you could do it
then you sort of could do anything with
it
then it got a bit easier to do but it
got more institutionalized and then
there are more constraints
so
it's it's it's challenging and and for
example doing something like starting a
company and i mean i myself have done
sort of a mixture of of running
companies and running a company for the
same same company for 35 years um
and uh
and doing um uh doing research and so on
and yes there is a a certain i mean for
me personally
running the company
is
you know i've been doing long and doing
it long enough i'm fairly experienced at
it it's not something that that creates
a sort of huge distraction for me from
from what uh from what i want to do
intellectually and actually i find it
rather invigorating to not just be oh
i'm i'm sitting and thinking all day
every day type thing i've got other
things to do
but i think this question about whether
um
whether
sort of
getting the best people whatever that
means to be able to thrive it's a really
challenging thing throughout history i
mean in
at
different times people had
uh kind of you know sponsors um
uh oh gosh what they called um
uh
people who would um
uh you know it would be
you know the duke of such and such a
place would be
the um uh the kind of the sponsor of
such and such a scientist and yes that
person would um
um
uh would kind of um help uh you know
that the person the scientist will be
wheeled in every so often to come and
help you know solve the problem of the
castle moat or something like this
um but otherwise they were just people
who were uh kind of in the orbit so to
speak supported by
uh some benefactor or other
but i think that the um
the thing that um
uh
so so that was sort of a thing for a
while but it's a very hit-and-miss kind
of thing i mean there are endless
stories about people who went in and out
of favor or or they were supported by
this king who got deposed or or this and
that kind of thing so it was a very you
know people were investing in those
relationships and then it was kind of
hit and miss about whether you would get
somebody who would be kind of your
sponsor or not
then
i would say that uh
there have been times in history
where
it's been kind of the
um
you know when when isaac newton went to
cambridge university i don't know what
was involved in getting into cambridge
university i think they had tests of
some kind um i bet those tests were not
you know the highly gamified sats
um those were and at different times in
history
there's been sort of a mechanism
where
uh it's actually rather in in some cases
rather nice
where it's been like sort of anybody
from the country can you know sign up
for the test
and if they do well in the test they get
a slot in the prestigious university or
whatever i mean that mechanism
is good when it's small when there are
small number of people signing up for
those tests where the tests are sort of
quite personalized uh you know when you
are writing essays and people who really
understand the essays of reading the
essays those kinds of things it all
works well when it becomes heavily
industrialized and you've got you know
millions of people taking tests and you
know
multiple choice or ai's grading essays
and things like that i think it all gets
a bit crazy and you're measuring
something which i don't think you're
measuring uh sort of the raw you know a
person from everywhere can come and and
uh be the most successful you're
measuring all kinds of things about how
committed were people to doing test prep
how able were they to get access to
fancy test prep uh kinds of capabilities
all those kinds of things which which
might be a relevant factor to measure if
what you want to know is you know will
they pay the will they pay their fees
for the university or will they even
succeed in getting through x number of
years of university if that's your
objective but are those people going to
be the best
the most innovative the people who move
society forward the most probably not
the probably not a good way to measure
that but i think in um uh and and
similarly in the entrepreneurial world i
suppose the same type of thing there was
a time when
it was very
uh what was like kind of the um um
uh the the um
the kind of uh the sponsors of of the
scientists of old you know if you knew
somebody and you knew somebody then you
could kind of slot yourself into that
commercial world i think it became in a
sense more opened up
but then also
more kind of uh structured and less
capable of dealing with kind of the high
innovation side of it
anyway that's uh a few thoughts on that
um
let's see
my gosh there's a question from emmanuel
kant probably not the real one
unfortunately um
do i credit e equals m c squared to
einstein or somebody else called depreto
we discovered it before einstein i'm
afraid i've never heard of that other
person
i don't know the detailed history of e
equals m c squared um i think
the thing that again
is
you know when you talk about discovering
something like that
there is the formula and writing it down
and there is the context that leads to
it and kind of the understanding of what
that is
and
that formula comes out of the context of
relativity theory
as a sort of an inevitable consequence
it isn't
the it's hard to imagine
that that formula
uh was was something that
would be and the way it has been seen i
i think we have a little bit of a
different interpretation last couple of
years but but the way it has been seen
for a solid hundred years
is
as something which is kind of a
a consequence
and a sort of an implication almost a
footnote to relativity theory and in
that context it's hard to see how it
arises without the structure of
relativity theory
now
you know the thing that's often
confusing about history of science is
somebody will say look this person had
this one idea that looks like this thing
that emerged later it didn't have that
whole context around it and then you
have to ask
was that one idea really
the same idea the same thing or was it
just something that sort of floated in
and was not in the end the thing that
was properly intellectually connected
and and really was the thing that was a
full understanding of what was going on
i mean i think we see that in um oh i
don't know you know you could say
of um
what's a good example
uh
black holes let's say laplace
in the 1700s talked about
you know stars where the escape velocity
would be more than the speed of light
which is kind of the idea of black holes
did laplacin discover black holes
not really because laplace didn't know
about the curvature of space-time and
event horizons and singularities in in
space-time and so on
laplace correctly identified a physical
effect that is related to black holes
where you can say well it would have
been a black hole but but laplace didn't
know that there was more to the story
than just the escape velocity becomes
more than the speed of light
but yet he did understand that part of
the story but that wasn't really
connected to the later discoveries about
black holes which were took a long time
to happen
in um uh in general relativity and so on
let's see
uh
there's a question here
about is there a from indifferent is
there a high period of any institution
that's my favorite eg bell labs
um
in uh
uh 40s xerox park in the 70s and 80s and
so on
um
i'm not sure i have a favorite but it is
fascinating to see
these different institutions
that
developed a culture where just lots was
discovered
and i saw both bell labs and xerox park
i i was a consultant at bell labs i
visited xerox park
during their sort of uh i would say
uh definitely a
bell labs really on the on the later end
of its golden age um
xerox park probably uh right during its
golden age
and
i think it's very interesting
what the kind of the management
structures of these organizations tended
to be and also the hiring practices of
these organizations
because
in a sense
you know there was a question earlier
about universities
in the time
you know
universities were sort of
originally from the 1200s and so on
there had been a notion of scholars
and scholars you know study things in
detail and so on it is not necessarily
for the scholar
to invent the brand new thing i mean i
was kind of amused seeing um some stuff
from edison
at some point and and howard hughes as
well
where you know these were people who
were kind of in the inventor-ish set
and they would occasionally bring in
professors
but they brought in professors
not to be
the great innovators they brought in the
professors to kind of fill in the
details and like well we need to
understand some particular thing about
meteorology we need to understand some
particular thing about materials science
let's bring in a scholar let's bring in
a professor to to kind try and do that
kind of recognizing the fact that for a
long time academia was about this
process of scholarship which is a little
different from the process of innovation
i mean there clearly are examples like
isaac newton for example
like well i mean einstein is a good
example of a bad example so to speak
because although he had a a perfectly he
had a good
uh sort of uh top quality
university to phd level education in
physics
um the the actual first job he had was
in the kind of the the then equivalent
of silicon valley you know the patent
office in in in burn um where you know
that was the place where you know
refrigeration techniques and so on were
all coming through the patent office and
it was kind of the um uh the the sort of
combo
venture capital silicon valley uh sort
of hub of its time and so einstein was
working there at the time when he did
his most uh
sort of first round of most creative
work
um rather than at a university so to
speak and i think perhaps that the um uh
the tradition of universities
uh you know it's a complicated thing
what what's the point of a university i
mean back in the 1200s it was this kind
of roving band of uh kind of somewhat
monk-like scholars
who were trying to uh
sort of teach about things that were not
part of necessarily what um you know
they were trying to educate people about
sort of the the wisdom from aristotle
and and and elsewhere um that was um
uh that was sort of you know preserving
that knowledge and passing it on to
future generations
scholars doing that
then this idea that universities are the
place where sort of innovation happens
um is a more recent idea i think it
happened a bunch
well it happened in german universities
a bunch
like in england for example there would
be places like the royal institution
that was
uh
essentially a a a science research and
presenting to the public place not a
university it just a a sort of separate
i don't really know what the analog of
that would be in today's world
um it's uh uh it's something that was
um i mean it's a little bit like a
government lab but it isn't really like
the mission of a standard government lab
it's a different kind of thing that's
where people like faraday
and davey and so on worked um again a
different kind of place and i think that
there's a certain
uh i have to say i think there is often
a certain energy
to
places that have
uh are not
kind of in this in this large-scale flow
of people doing sort of in a in a kind
of industrial scale track of doing some
particular kind of thing and sometimes
when places are newer there's more
energy associated with these things i
think probably
in the us
when universities expanded dramatically
well
for example in the technical areas after
sputnik in 1957 and so on when there was
lots of funding put in from the
government and so on into universities
and developing research at universities
that was probably a period of great
productivity when kind of uh
universities were the hot place so to
speak for for innovation um you know i
think that um
there's a certain
what can i say there's a certain
different
well there are different types of people
who can succeed
in institutions of different kinds and
at different stages in those
institutions
i think that for example at universities
today i can't really speak about them
that much today i haven't been so much
involved in them but certainly used to
be the case that research was not
managed at universities if you were a
professor at a university nobody told
you what research to do you just did
what you did if you could get government
funding great if you couldn't well that
was that was bad but there was nobody
there was no manager at the university
saying hey you should work on this
rather than that you know department
chairman or president of the university
perish the thought actually telling
people what they should work on and what
they should not work on that would be uh
you know the faculty would would come
out with pitchforks and so on in that
case
well
so whereas at a place like bell labs or
xerox park
there was kind of an overarching sort of
management uh
uh both both um implicit and explicit
kind of this is what we're trying to
achieve this is how we can do something
sort of go in strategic directions and
so on and i think that
that probably had for for many people
that had a you know it's always very
valuable for many people that had kind
of a positive effect i mean there have
been different mechanisms over the
course of time
for sort of institutions
where there are sort of interesting
innovations that happen for example
oxford and cambridge in england where
there's this college system and where
people are fellows of colleges and so on
uh used to be the case that you were a
fellow of this college and that was kind
of all you were at the university then
by the by the mid 20th century it was
much more there was a department of x
that was really induced i think by
science when people needed you know you
needed a lab and that wasn't going to
happen in you know this college it was
something that wanted to be centralized
for the university but you know for for
quite a while there were sort of the
people who were the fellows of colleges
and things and they would often get
those fellowships pretty early in life
right after they got their bachelor's
degrees and so on and um and then they
would kind of be somehow in the orbit of
that college maybe they would be sort of
permanently living there maybe they
would be kind of uh just uh
going there from time to time but uh
that they were somehow sort of supported
to do it at least at some level
supported to do whatever academic thing
they were supposed they wanted to do and
that that was for for many people that
was sort of a a good deal there are
plenty of of sort of innovations in that
one can point to that came out of people
who were embedded in that kind of system
so
anyway i think that that that um
uh
uh you know it's always interesting to
see companies
um
will get to a point where they say we're
so successful
we need a basic research lab or we need
a research lab
and i've seen this in many companies
i've even been involved in in and giving
some advice to people about how to how
to set these things up
it's a very challenging thing because
you're a company you've made a bunch of
money you've got to you say we're going
to we want to plan for the future to do
that we need to have more basic research
we're going to bring people in
but then there's the question of can you
take the innovations that you know what
happens to that for example
when your company
isn't quite as profitable anymore what
do you do to the basic research lab do
you just say oops you know those hundred
million hundreds of millions of dollars
that were going to basic research let's
cut that off the budget because that way
it'll look better for our stockholders
so to speak and nobody's going to notice
that we cut the basic research lab
that's happened a bunch of times
the um then there's the question of okay
you have a very successful lab like
xerox park for example it invents
amazing stuff
but the mothership company can't do
anything with it it doesn't have a
mechanism to get that uh get that
innovation back into the into the main
company i i remember a bell labs when i
was there um
uh
my friend rob pike um made this thing
called the blit terminal along with uh
uh
bart well kathy i think was the other
person's name um the uh was a the blitz
terminal was a a bitmap display terminal
this was
1982-ish time frame
was a um
a kind of it's like a chromebook it was
kind of a a um a local device
that
would be
um
uh
uh would
it was kind of a way of using the phone
lines because bell labs was after all
part of the phone company and it was the
idea was there was a central computer
and then you would have this this local
thin client device that had a nice
bitmap screen
and the computing would be done on the
remote computer and then the um uh you
would have your sort of local
interaction on this blitz terminal
device
it was very very modern in many many
ways
it was very frustrating i think for the
researchers involved because try as they
might they just couldn't get the the
actual
uh you know corporate entity to pay
attention to this thing and to start
actually putting it into production and
you know providing it to phone
subscribers and things like this didn't
really happen
at that time there was kind of a an
interesting competition between
uh this the blit terminal kind of idea
the thin client idea where where sort of
it's just where the real computation is
done on the central kind of computer
power station so to speak and there's uh
some sort of edge computation done
wasn't called that in those days um on
uh on your local device
the other side of that was companies
like sun microsystems where the idea was
to make a workstation computer using
typically the then new motorola 68000
microprocessors which were able to have
they could have sufficient address space
and so on to be able to to deal with
having
decent local computation and they had
bitmap displays and all that kind of
thing doing the computation locally so
it was kind of a competition should you
do it locally should you do it on the
main sort of centralized computer only
interacting with um uh you know only
having sort of local interface i
remember having dinner once with with
rob pike and bill joy who was um one of
the founders of sun microsystems and um
it was a uh a kind of a a big kind of um
well i would say
debate might be a a a polite way to put
it about sort of who would win
in the um uh the kind of local computing
um versus the remote computing thing and
i have to say at that time i thought the
remote computing thing had a better
better arguments going for it but for
reasons of uh mostly i would say the the
uh the way that sort of the ingestion of
research from bell labs into the main
company being really challenging thing
that didn't what happened um instead you
know the workstation companies won it
was interesting at that time there were
several
workstation companies some microsystems
come out of stanford sun stood for
stanford university network i remember
seeing the original prototype of that in
a cardboard box um at stanford um but
that was that was one system there was
another one from a company called apollo
it's based on the east coast
um an interesting thing
about sort of the technology assumptions
uh sun had the idea that there was the
operating system underneath there was a
unix operating system on top there was a
window system that provided the user
interface
apollo had it more or less the other way
around windows system underneath
operating system on top
turned out that second thing just was
really hard to make work
because you had the windows system was
just in a sense a much more complicated
creature than the the operating system
and so it was it tended you know things
would topple over so to speak as a
result of problems in the window system
and if there were problems in the
windows system on a kind of the sun
model you would just fall through the
operating system but that wasn't so bad
let's see
there's a question here about um
from eggy about what technology got lost
from the moon landing they can't repeat
it so that it can't be repeated today
how did they shield from radiation
during the moon mission
you know i think if you look at pictures
of the lamb when it landed
it's it's covered in gold foil
um that was
in order to shield from radiation
because
the uh the probability of a ionizing
particle of radiation being scattered
from an atom increases like the square
of the atomic number of the atom and so
a substance like lead like like well
lead or gold um gold because i think it
can be made better into a foil
that was the thing that was used to
shield from from radiation i think
as far as technology being lost
i think it's always the case that people
you have a group of people they solve a
bunch of engineering problems
and then those people move on retire die
whatever
and then it's hard to get back to the
level that level of expertise again and
you know i i see that even in our
technology company it's like there's the
thing we developed it 10 years ago and
it's like nobody remembers how that
really worked and why we made those
choices and and so on and to sort of
bring it back out of mothballs but we
are pretty good at archiving things but
it's it's often not trivial to do that
and i think what happened in the apollo
program during the 1960s the whole space
program thing was just a a sort of
spectacular uh puller in of talent um in
in the us
a lot of that talent when when the
apollo program kind of got cancelled um
in the
1971 or so
um
quite a lot of that talent migrated to
silicon valley um and that was and it
kind of dissipated and so then getting
back that kind of expertise is not
trivial because it's like oh that person
so and so over there
knew
um
uh you know knew all about such and such
a thing um and oh they're off now
working for hewlett-packard or something
or varian associates or one of the early
silicon valley companies um and they're
not uh
you know we haven't heard from them for
ages and you know they're off doing a
different thing so it's hard to sort of
reconstruct that knowledge um it's not
my impression that
there are things where people say we
just don't know at all how this was done
there are detailed things where it
probably isn't known but there are also
things where where it's like who
you know the early the computer
computers on the lem
were
sort of only semi-programmable computers
and they involved people doing things
like actually sort of knitting wires
through magnetic cores and so on uh
changing them depending on when the when
the you know the spacecraft is going to
be launched things like this
those are things which yeah we probably
don't know how those were done in detail
but it really doesn't matter anymore
because you know we if we were doing
that we would emulate it in software
today so to speak it's a quite different
technology stack
um there are things where
uh there's sort of the question like a
rocket engine for example you know the
the design of rocket engines is a
difficult thing and it's been kind of a
a piece of engineering that's gradually
got better over the course of you know
60 years or 70 years or whatever it is
more than that now um and you know why
is rocket engine why is a rocket engine
hard to design you know you look at a
rocket engine it's full of all these
tubes and pipes and and valves and all
kinds of things it's like why should it
be so hard isn't it just you know you're
burning a rocket fuel and it it produces
uh exhaust gases the reason is that in
order to make it efficient it tends to
be that these things are operating right
close to phase transitions and it's
you're having to very carefully control
you know the rate of burning versus the
rate of this versus the rate of that and
these substances end up being in in
these funny funny situations where
different things are happening and you
know if this happens there's some over
pressure valve that has to cut you know
do this and that and the other and it's
it's a difficult thing that's been
gradually tweaked over the course of
years i think people say that the thing
that limits most rocket engines is the
the uh the turbo pump that tries to just
pump fuel into the into the combustion
chamber i think that's what sort of
limits the um but the very fact that
that's a limiting factor rather than
something uh you know rather than
something which is sort of the pure
physics of the rocket is kind of part of
why that's difficult and and why i think
there's a sort of an unbroken thread of
progressive development of rocket
engines um over the course of time
and uh so that's a place where i think
the technology is not that different i
know spacex for example licensed old
russian designs when they started out
um and uh that was you know a place
where you're sort of grandfathering on
top of things that have been done before
because there's just a lot of sort of
built up um kind of knowledge um through
the course of lots of probably lots of
failed rocket tests lots of blown up
rockets things like this
so i i think that's the um um
uh that's that's kind of the story there
um
let's see
uh
there's a question here
about um
uh
from freaks
what what do i think about things like
the sentiments about racism and
technology and algorithmic bias
and what's the issue what are steps that
need to be taken in response that is a
a hugely complicated question
it's i think the thing to understand
about questions like that
is
in the end you need some moral code that
you think you want to follow
and people may not agree about what that
code should be
once you have that code you can go back
and sort of tell the computers to
execute it
what but before you know that code it's
hard to know what you should do so to
speak i mean a a sort of a famous
example is
you know you have an image search system
you type in ceo what kinds of people do
you get
do you get
the
uh you know do you get men women black
white you know
asian non-a you know what what what type
of person do you get well okay you can
ask the question who are the current
ceos of tech companies for example well
there's some answer to that there's a
definite objective answer to that
question who would we like the ceos of
tech companies to be well it kind of
depends on our sort of moral code and a
bunch of beliefs about society and so on
and people might not agree about that
and so the question is what you know
what should the what should the search
engine do
should it kind of tip the scale in in
favor of the way one might want things
to be based on some moral code or should
it just report what's out there right
now even if what's out there like right
now might not be the way one wants it to
be
those are difficult questions and i
think that uh there's a certain
there's a sort of a question of what is
the role of technology in and technology
companies in those kinds of in those
kinds of issues is it something where
you're just reporting the facts so to
speak or is it something where you if
you believe you that the scale should be
tipped should you be involved in tipping
the scale so to speak and i think it
tends to be the case
that that sort of reporting it as it is
versus describing it as you would like
it to be or as somebody would like it to
be
is is a difficult thing to decide i mean
this comes up a lot
in um in things where one's doing i
don't know algorithmic uh estimates of
uh you know credits of of uh credit
worthiness or or you know possible
success in this or that or the other
there's there's there's kind of the what
it has been and the what does the what
it what you want it to be
and it's you know it's a difficult thing
because it tends to be the case
that the uh uh you know reporting it as
it has been or using what it has been
tends to be
kind of something which will
you know it it it perpetuates that cycle
and one might say that is not what one
wants to have happen but one has to make
an active decision that's not what we
wants to have happen and i think one has
to have one has to specify what it is
one wants to have happen and expose that
and if one can agree on that well then
one can get the ais to follow if one
can't agree on that it's kind of tough
to tell the computers what to do if the
humans are all off arguing about it then
the computers really don't know what to
do and if you say well let's let the
computers decide that's hopeless because
the that they have no there's no
intrinsic moral code sort of defined for
an ai that's something where the goals
that we set have to be goals set by
humans and that's something where if you
say you know the the bright idea might
be well let's just have the ais watch
what the humans do and emulate that well
that's again
back to just do what has been done in
the past which might not be what you
want or many people would agree that um
i don't know this i'm reminded of some
uh some kind of uh amusing sort of
science fiction movie which had some uh
robot in it which um had been uh you
know learning to drive and it
accelerated every time it saw a yellow
light because it said well that's what
the humans do
and um the uh
but it might not be what you would want
the the ai to do so to speak it might be
uh uh so i think there was a it's it's a
very very complicated area where i think
that um the thing that people perhaps
sometimes
make a mistake about
is it's it's not really a
technologically solvable problem it's
something where you have to decide what
you want and there's much argument
perhaps about what you want
once you have that decision then you can
implement that in technology the role of
i mean sort of an interesting question
what um uh you know what the role of a
company versus a government
versus people on their own should be in
trying to figure these kinds of things
out
my own personal prejudice tends to be
that companies should stay out of it
that companies have some business that
they're doing that's i don't know
providing software or services or
whatever and that's a different problem
than the problem of setting kind of
moral code for things on the other hand
there are certainly cases in which one
can say a company definitely shouldn't
do that because it's really really you
know a terrible thing and history has
shown that um a bunch of times so it's
it's a it's a difficult problem
and um
uh
i think um you know you'd be
you know i certainly um
i could tell you many kind of um
stories about for example training image
identification systems
and there are all sorts of terrible
things there i mean there are all sorts
of things where
you will if you if you try and pick it
up you know train the system based on
sort of
what is typical and what has been there
in the past you end up with things which
are yes that's what's been there in the
past and nobody thinks that's good but
probably almost nobody thinks that's
good but what are you going to do to
train your system unless you have some
moral code that defines what you want to
have happen it's tough to say how you
how you should change that
um
let's see maybe one or two more
here
okay there's a question from aaron
do i think that monotheistic religion
was in some sense a precursor to science
because it presented the world as having
a single truth which all people could
somehow access
that's interesting i i've been thinking
a little bit about uh
theology more than religion
recently because a bunch of the sort of
philosophical questions that have come
out of our science project
are questions about kind of the
relationship of humans to the universe
and the extent to which
our kind of uh human ways of thinking
about things define how we view the
universe this this extent to which sort
of uh
what what the global picture of the
universe really is and one of the things
i find really interesting about that is
there were lots of early theologians
who thought about these questions well
there are people like plato and so on
who were not really uh in any modern
sense sort of theologically oriented um
but then there were people from uh i
don't know
um
saint augustine through aquinas through
all kinds of people like that who were
absolutely kind of theologically
motivated and even people like descartes
had a certain theological strand to what
they were doing or spinoza or any of
these kinds of people um and there were
questions that got thought about by
those people
that were
that turn out to be very much the same
kind of questions that we are confronted
with now as we think about sort of the
global implications of our science
project and even the ways to think about
the sort of the fundamental nature of
physics humans mathematics and so on
we're sort of confronted with the same
questions that people thought about when
the primary topic was theology and so i
my impression is what happened is a lot
of those questions about you know why is
there order in the universe
um what uh
is the is the universe sort of the set
of all possible things that can happen
is there
all these kinds of issues
and i think a lot of um
a lot of that thinking
kind of got squashed as soon as kind of
modern science at the time of galileo
and newton in the 1600s and so on
started up people said well there were
questions we wanted to ask about kind of
how the heavens work and so on and those
questions well this modern science stuff
this mathematical science is doing
really well at that let's just follow
that path
and not uh and you know this theological
thinking well you know there was the
whole copernicus galileo debacle and it
just seems like those guys were off on
the wrong track
um and and so then the sort of the
science track got followed the fact is
the theology track was thinking about
questions which were different from the
science track questions those questions
are a little bit back now and in fact
it's pretty interesting to go see what
the theologians said because a lot of
what they said was really pretty smart
um it just was stuff that was different
in a different direction than the kinds
of things that were thought about in
terms of of uh of science
and for example monotheistic religion
it's sort of a a thing where where this
kind of idea that you go up and it's
bigger and it's bigger and it's bigger
and it's bigger and eventually you get
to the end and it's everything and what
is it well it's kind of a god-like thing
and there's one of it this idea that
there's a bigger bigger bigger and then
there's the end and that's the
everything and there's one everything
and not many other things
was i think kind of the conceptual uh
for many for some of those theologians
at least that was the kind of conceptual
origin of god
and you know people like from spinoza um
uh
even i think godel had some
rather different point of view on this
but but this idea of sort of the limit
of um of everythingness was god and
there was only one of it
now mathematically that isn't really
quite right because as one discovered
with transfinite numbers and all this
kind of thing that idea of the sequence
and there's always a largest element is
not quite the right story but that was a
that was the sort of approximating story
that i think led to kind of this uh this
sort of monotheism has to be the way it
is because there's always a biggest
everything
and obviously then it it it got many
other tentacles of of uh of thinking
about the relationship of everything to
humans and and all kinds of other all
kinds of other issues and and sort of
then got bundled together with the more
sort of uh how to lead your life stories
of religion
and this was also combined with the fact
that the the mode of explanation was not
you know if we're going to explain
you know right and wrong we will write
down a formula type thing it was more if
or if we're going to even explain how
the universe works we'll write down a
formula it was more told in stories and
allegories and so on because that was
the method of communicating kind of
intellectual ideas that was available at
the time just as if you if you asked you
know what did uh democritus or epicurus
or somebody like that say about atoms uh
back in in the you know whatever fifth
century bc or something that it was not
um
it was not we'll write down a formula
for brownian motion or whatever it was a
description of atoms and almost a story
about what was happening with atoms um
and so i think that's that's that's that
kind of approach now i i think it is
interesting
that a bunch of uh
a bunch of sort of development in
science happened
in places where monotheistic religions
were big
um i you know what's the correlation
between those things i'm not sure the
there was also science development
happening in places where there weren't
monotheistic religions so i don't know
um what uh um
the extent to which that um uh that was
relevant now it is interesting perhaps
uh you mentioned that the idea that um
presented the world is a place with a
single truth that that uh all people
could access
that's interesting i mean i i that
that's an interesting thought um that
somehow
the uh
um
that the idea
that there is uh the the this idea of
everything you know the everything thing
um that that was sort of uh reflected in
everything
and that that meant that it wasn't
something where it's like there's one
thing over here and one thing over there
maybe maybe that is something relevant
to the globality of science i mean i
think that the the the sort of the the
starting point in a sense for science
uh which curiously was also an argument
made for the existence of god
was the existence of order in the
universe it's like the universe could be
a completely disordered place where
every particle is doing its own thing
but it's not it's instead a place where
there are definite laws that go across
the whole universe now our understanding
of that now in terms of our physics
project and this whole rouliad idea and
so on is is rather different and rather
nuanced and really has the idea that
actually the universe does have
everything going on it is merely our
particular way of viewing the universe
from our particular place in rulial
space just as we have a particular place
in physical space that leads us to our
particular view of the universe with the
particular laws that we attribute to the
universe so we're really going against
away from the idea that the the universe
itself is imposing these laws that are
the laws of the universe rather we're
saying
at the base level at the kind of real
sort of ur level of the universe all
possible laws are being followed it's
merely that in our way of observing the
universe we attribute to the universe
certain particular laws so this idea
that the laws come from
come from the universe
sort of come from god in a sense having
imposed that particular set of laws on
the universe that would be that would
have been a point of view of of the
theologians for quite a while i think
our point of view is a sense a more
bizarre point of view perhaps but one by
the way that probably is reflected in
some theological thought that the
universe is everything
really everything and all possibilities
and all possible laws and unlaws and so
on but it is merely our human
interaction with it that gives it the
kind of order that we humans perceive in
it and so that's kind of a case where
where there's so you can you can perhaps
tell that some of those arguments those
arguments are not the arguments that you
see in modern mathematical physics those
are those are arguments that are much
more in in resonance with arguments that
people
have tried to make over the course of
studying theology than arguments that
people have made in the sort of
specifics of mathematical physics
but they're arguments that you kind of
have to untangle if you want to
understand questions like well one that
i've been greatly interested in recently
are mathematics and physics at the
bottom fundamentally the same thing and
merely being seen in different ways by
by us humans so to speak and and that um
uh for that you have to have a better
understanding of the relationship of
humans to this thing that is sort of the
everything of the universe
but i think um this
this idea
that uh
um
that sort of all humans
have yeah this is an interesting thing i
mean this question of do all humans have
access to the same truth so to speak
you know this has clearly been uh the
whole sort of relativism uh kind of
movement
has kind of
had one twist on that
you might think that our kind of
theories would be the the sort of the
most relativist theories you can imagine
because they're saying the actual laws
of the universe are determined by
characteristics of us but but it only
goes so far because it turns out it
needs only a few characteristics of us
to give us sort of all the laws of the
universe
so our details actually don't matter so
it's kind of a relativism relative to
the aliens but certainly not
from sort of human to human so to speak
but i think in in um
uh you know these questions about
for example the fact that science is a
global activity and sort of most people
more or less believe the same science
is interesting
mathematics same way you know it could
be mathematics with its notation as it
exists today grew up in particular 1600s
at a time when there had been a sort of
universal language of learning at least
in the west which was latin and that was
kind of decaying and people were going
to you know french english german etc as
italian whatever as as languages of of
scholarship and and there was sort of an
active effort to try and standardize
mathematical notation let's have an
international language of mathematics so
to speak
um i think that science
because it hasn't been such a big field
has ended being ended up being sort of
scattered throughout the world and most
of the time science is kind of uh you
know it's the same science is more or
less believed more or less around the
world we've seen that lots and this
pandemic for example that people aren't
off having very different science
theories in different parts of the world
for better or worse in medicine it's not
quite so obviously the case i mean
there's sort of traditional medicine in
countries like china i don't know how
big that is these days but my impression
is there's still
quite a lot of kind of the western
medicine versus traditional medicine
whether it hasn't completely flattened
out
across the world i mean some aspects of
it have and there's certainly some
commercial pressure to see that happen
but i don't think it has completely
happened yet um i think it's it's
interesting that science probably by
virtue of being a comparatively small
field
with high mobility of people has become
something that is largely global it
isn't the case that people say
you know during the cold war for example
uh
in physics
you know i was involved in the in the
business at that time and you could ask
was there american physics and soviet
physics
you know were they you know were they
separated and the answer is a bit yes
there were things that were popular in
american physics
and they were different from things that
were popular in soviet physics for
example in soviet physics there was a
you know computers weren't really a big
thing there and there was a lot more
emphasis on kind of elaborate
mathematical calculation
there plenty of that in the in american
physics too but there was more of an
emphasis in soviet physics there were
types of questions that were explored
and i would say i would say if you could
if you showed me a physics paper
from i don't know late 1970s or
something like that
and sort of blinded it and said was this
a soviet paper an american paper it
wouldn't be hard to tell it wouldn't be
hard to tell because the approach will
be somewhat different uh sometimes the
notation was a bit different
um and uh but it was so that was a case
where where physics had not globalized
whereas i would say now probably it's
it's it's pretty globalized in that
sense so i don't know to what extent the
uh
uh the the
you know i would say that the
the rise of of um
uh well another point to make about the
sort of the religions and so on versus
the sciences there were plenty of
institutional structures that were
spread by religions and which once you
had the concept of a such and such an
organizational structure
and you were going to feed people into
it among them scientists it was kind of
like well you could you know the places
covered by i don't know the catholic
church or something or were were going
to have some uniformity and so there was
going to be some possibility of sort of
that same institutional structure and
those same kinds of people operating in
those in across all those places which
would lead to a certain uniformization
in the kinds of thinking that were going
on in science at that time
but i don't i it's a good question your
original question is a good question and
i don't i don't um uh don't have a great
um
uh answer to that
um
all right i should probably wrap this up
in just a moment here see if there's
anything i think i can handle
quickly famous last words
um
let's see there's a question here which
doesn't seem like it's a quick question
but it's a really fun one from fred why
did it take so long to get so scientific
so technically
advanced in the in other words
if you went back
and you know there's sometimes these
movies where um somebody you know is
time traveler and they go and take a um
uh it was one just recently wasn't there
about um where it's like um somebody is
the the magic inventor because they take
this thing from the future back to the
distant past and that's the seed that uh
that sets you know technology off in a
certain direction you know imagine you
took a laptop back to ancient greece or
something
what would you do with it what would
what would be the conclusion about it
what would be the um uh you know can you
accelerate technology development is
technology development just about having
ideas or is there a big infrastructure
development that's needed you know is it
critical that you have you know clean
water or something to be able to do
certain manufacturing processes is it
critical and i think what tends to be
the case
is that there's an awful lot
in the sort of development of technology
that's not ideas based that is really
based on just the progressive
development of infrastructure to let you
do more and more you know precision
engineering to let you do this to figure
out how you mine this kind of material
etc etc etc now each step there probably
required an idea to get you know to
solve that engineering problem but in a
sense there's this whole stack of
engineering problems that had to be
solved in order to get you to the point
where you could build something in a
particular way and sort of the idea
alone i mean if
leibniz back in the late 1600s had
really grocked the idea of universal
computation what would he have done with
it you know he had built this brass you
know mechanical calculator but could he
have uh you know said universal
computation now i can go and build
computers you know could babbage for
example 1840s
was talking about making a giant
analytical engine you never built an
analytical engine in the end but uh you
know ada lovelace was going to be the
ceo of the analytical engine company but
um unfortunately that didn't work out
because she got sick but um um the uh
she was um uh you know the concept was
they were gonna build this giant
analytical engine
steam-powered you know mechanical thing
maybe they would have made the jump to
an electromechanical not not sure but um
they're going to build this thing in the
1840s and it was going to be the cloud
computing of its day so to speak um that
didn't happen
uh for sort of unfortunate personal
reasons i think at the time but um in in
um uh it could have been
that um
uh
it um
uh you know would would that
uh you know
what would that have done to the sort of
trajectory of technology and and to what
extent is it a question of sort of
having the idea like like a one that i
sometimes quote is you know newton
would have known that you could make an
artificial satellite
but
you know fortunately for him
he didn't make a satellite launch
company he didn't invest in the south
sea company which led which uh was
involved in the south sea bubble um but
so he was a he was definitely a sort of
entrepreneurial investor but he didn't
invest in the you know the spacex of
1690 or something um because there
wasn't one and that was a few hundred
years too early um so you know i think
this question of of what does it take to
get to a certain level of technology i
think it takes lots of of small pieces
of infrastructure development that all
have to build up to get to the point
where you can actually do a certain kind
of technology and that's that's why
uh it i mean
the the um you know this is one of the
great achievements of our civilization
that we've built up all this expertise
all these engineering capabilities all
these supply chains actually of uh of
how you know you get this and that
material to this and that place and
assemble it in this in that way so i
think it's it's um uh you know the main
answer is just that it involves these
many many steps
of engineering development
and production manufacturing
developments and so on that are sort of
inexorably take a long time and it isn't
really a question of you just have to
have that one brilliant idea and you can
kind of jump many hundreds of years into
the future now you know it's interesting
in an area like software
where
the um it's that's probably perhaps less
true
because
even in my own efforts
you know a bunch of the ideas about
symbolic programming and so on that we
use today in wolfram language and and so
on and that are still i would say sort
of uh
many years in the future so to speak in
terms of really widespread understanding
you know i came up with those ideas
leveraging a bunch of ideas for
mathematical logic back in the in you
know around 1980 um and that was in a
sense uh in a sense that was sort of the
just an idea idea because you know
implementing the software aspects of it
are somewhat challenging but once you
have the once you have things committed
to software there is less of this need
for the engineering stack than there is
in in the production of physical things
there's some need you know it's
important to have structured code and
you can you know tools for dealing with
large-scale code bases but honestly we
had pretty decent ones at least i had
built our team had built a bunch of
pretty decent ones back in the beginning
of the 1980s um that uh you know they're
not as sleek as the get of today or
something but they weren't terrible
source code control systems and and
things like that and so that's probably
a case where in software maybe it is
possible to make these jumps that are
just idea based jumps unfortunately
sometimes you make an idea to base jump
and while you can do wonderful things
with it people can't necessarily
understand what that jump was
and uh the the kind of the widespread
use of it may take a lot longer like
fifty hundred more years um to happen
all right well we should probably uh
wrap up here and um uh
um
on to uh i'll be doing another one of
these probably in the new year
and look forward to seeing you then and
uh
probably being able to address a few
questions that i didn't get to today
all right